so we talk a lot about the economic
stress that's facing Brazil rising
inflation rising unemployment falling
retail sales what about the state Rio
specifically what is the situation on
that state's finances how is it doing
yes sir Rio is one of the states that's
been most affected by the by the falling
oil prices
Rio is one of the oil producers and it's
also dealing with a big pension deficit
that that accounts for about three
fifths of the projected deficit this
year and so really the the state's
struggling to to pay you know public
officials struggling to pay teachers
everyone is is having to you know bear
the brunt of this right and I'm
wondering how does that compare to 2009
when they first one this bit sort of
marketing themselves as a flourishing
economy that could handle this Olympics
well yeah in 2009 you had you know
thousands of people on Copacabana beach
you know celebrating when when it was
actually awarded you had Lula making
these grand proclamations that it was it
was Brazil's time and now it wouldn't be
seen as a second-class country in a
really booming economy in you know in
2010 2009 was a very very small
recession whereas the rest of the world
just was mired in the global financial
crisis so it's really been quite the
turnaround well David I mean all this
may be the case but to what extent will
tourists or the athletes themselves even
notice the problems well the big
question mark right now for the events
is going to be the Metro if they can
finish the Metro on time that's gonna
make things a lot smoother they have a
very narrow window there have been a lot
of delays and right now they're planning
to open it four days before the games
begin on a partial schedule and they're
still waiting on a one billion has loan
to finish the work so you know they they
say they're confident it's gonna finish
you know four days is four days so
that's the big one and then otherwise
you know it they might people might not
notice so much a lot of
these things are things that really
affect residents they'll they'll see the
bay that should have been cleaned up on
their way in they'll they'll smell it
too and other than that they probably
won't won't get a real feel for it
when was the metro supposed to have been
finished in the original plan I'm not
the exact date but it was definitely
several months ago is reading this this
report from the state auditor saying
that there was supposed to be 16 months
of tests before running the Metro and
instead it will have to well in terms of
the actual tourist money coming in is
there any hope that the influx of people
coming to see the games will provide
some sort of economic boost or is that
already sort of thrown off the table and
I guess it will you know help out the
hoteliers and stuff you know that bad
argument has been you know that picked
apart quite a bit that it provides this
economic boom a lot of questions about
that especially if they do have issues
with traffic say the Metro doesn't open
one thing they did during the World Cup
was declare public holidays you know it
sure it might help sectors that are
exposed to tourists but if the
population of the city isn't working you
know what does that do for the sort of
the balance so I think the question of
how much it helps at least at this
moment is is still there well in terms
of physical infrastructure there
certainly a lot to be desired here but
what about security to what extent will
Rios almost its state of being almost
broke affect security yeah well first of
all I'm just on the infrastructure thing
they obviously will have all this
infrastructure eventually it's more
about their whether the metro for
example is gonna be working for the
games that once it is done it will be a
great improvement on a roadway that's
terribly clogged right now on the
security front this year they've cut the
budget for security by one-third because
of all the financial problems and that's
you know that's obviously having a big
impact
high-ranking official I spoke to said
you know that there's still they still
have these these police with obsolete
gear the pioneering police program to
occupy favelas is starting to have a
backslide you're seeing gunfights up in
the hills in a way that you didn't see a
couple years ago crimes rising the
federal government is sending in the
National Guard that's part of the plan
that's not as a result of the budget
cuts but you know once they leave the
state is still in the same financial
quagmire and it's really a question of
you know what happens to Rio afterwards